Oh, Görx, Leute, da bin ich wieder und ich habe heute richtig Bock auf eine Runde Broga
Stels.
Guck mal, ob wir das hinkriegen, ich bin immer noch unschlüssig, woran es liegt.
Ich habe bisher nur das GitHub-Issue gelesen und das GitHub-Issue sagt, irgendwas mit
Watchdog-Fehler.
Keine Ahnung.
Mal gucken, was wir da rauskriegen.
Ähm, ich muss aber gerade mal kurz gucken, ob die Sounderde jetzt alles richtig.
Let's Player, G-E-R, moin.
Pog.
Ja, jetzt muss ich erstmal warten, bis Twitch gecheckt hat.
Dass der Stream online ist, das dauert immer ein bisschen.
Ich könnte bei der Gelegenheit schon mal meine VM anschalten, wie die ganz geilen Leute
das sagen.
Äh, Stream.
Wollte meinen Namen mal ändern, wieso?
Let's Player oder Let's Play Gear gibt es doch bestimmt nur 870 Mal schon.
Da weiß man bloß nicht, ob es Let's Player einfach nur falsch geschrieben ist oder ob
es Let's Play in Germany heißt soll.
Ich muss kurz was gucken, wartet mal kurz auf den zweiten Bildschirm, ich bin gleich
am Start, Stream läuft ja eh noch grad an, ok nice, so ich hab's geschafft, alles klar,
so da bin ich wieder, Wort CS, Pog Subscription, danke schön für den Sub, dazu kann man eigentlich
bloß sagen, extremely, Qemo wird IO FSD, wird replaced mit extras, wird IO FSD, ich weiß
noch nicht mal was, wird IO FSD, was ist FSD, weiß nicht mal was das sein soll, shared file
systems, ok ja, keine Ahnung, mach einfach, jawoll, gib ihm, ein giss, box subscription,
dankeschön, ich lasse meine Zeit bis das stream anläuft, mal meine vm updaten,
ja leute, schön dass ihr am start seid, wir kümmern uns heute um eines meiner open source
projects, es gibt nämlich einen bug unter ubuntu hab ich gesehen, ich wusste indirekt schon,
dass es den gibt, weil mal irgendjemand im stream da reingelaufen ist, aber heute hat einer noch
mal ein issue aufgemacht, auch wenn es jetzt kein riesen projekt ist oder so, aber es ist
tatsächlich mal interessant nachzugucken woran das liegt, oh die bayern sind da
und das gucken wir heute mal und natürlich wie immer wenn es irgendwas gibt zwischendurch wir
wir lassen uns ja prinzipiell eigentlich so gut wie nie sidetracken, ich glaube ich glaube ich
wurde noch nie, das könnt ihr bestätigen chat oder? achso das ist schweizer, du hast recht
selbstverständlich das habe ich jetzt ein bisschen verguckt, das ist die bayern sind ja eher so
mir san mir oder sowas in der richtung so hat das alles updated, sieht so aus ok kernel update da
rebooten wir mal wir machen aber vorher noch ein update das alles geupdatet ist und update
hogu time wir haben ja genug zeit ja also wie immer wenn irgendwas ist schreibt es in chat
weil ihr kennt mich ja ich werde prinzipiell nie sidetracked jetzt mal ehrlich jetzt mal ehrlich
chat jetzt mal wirklich so hand aufs herz gab es jemals einen stream in dem ich schon mal
gesidetracked wurde ich bezweifle das kann eigentlich nicht sein impossible wenn ihr nie
sidetracked habe ich neue dot files gepusht muss ich meine dot files pullen ich glaube ich muss
meine dot files pullen was habe ich denn was habe ich denn gemacht hier ich meine es ist immer gut
es ist immer gut wenn man so aussagekräftige commits hat wie ich ja update update update update
update update initial commit ist ja geil und heute habe ich wieder auf der arbeit einem erzählt so
nach dem motto ordentliche git commits und so alles klar erkennt man sofort oder? na gut ich meine hier
wurde was geupdated und in den folgen commits wurde auch was geupdated ob obviously ja wie
steht es um dein windows notebook das habe ich die letzten tage nicht mal verwendet ich habe mich zum
größten teil über schittricks verbunden und ich habe jetzt leute kann ich euch mal kurz erzählen
am anfang bevor das stream bevor das stream anläuft ich mache mal ich mache ein bisschen
orga zeug ich update immer mein greppel ich update mal meine idee und und und zeug dann kann
ich euch kann ich euch was bei erzählen und zwar ich habe jetzt was endlich ich kann endlich halbwegs
gescheit arbeiten auf der auf der arbeit klingt jetzt irgendwie nach ein bisschen ein bisschen
merkwürdig ja man geht ja auf die arbeit um zu arbeiten aber leute ich sage es euch ich habe
ein ultra krass restriktives windows notebook bekommen darauf kannst du nichts machen ich
wollte mir ein ordentliches terminal drauf installieren ging nicht zwar alles geblockt also
es ist alles geblockt was nicht explizit freigegeben ist komplett an usable in der form so die
windows geschichte aber was ich jetzt gemacht habe in kombination mit ein paar anderen frustrierten
linux admins haben wir hier mal update ist beziehungsweise ein kollega damit schon
angefangen ist jetzt folgendes wir haben uns jetzt alle bei google haben wir uns cloud linux cloud
vms aufgebaut und haben uns ein spezial proxy server angelegt der ins internet kann und jetzt
haben wir uns alle lokal wishell studio code freischalten lassen updating ja dann update
immer also update noch und wir haben uns alle lokal wishell studio code freischalten lassen
jetzt machen wir folgendes wir verbinden uns mit wishell studio code mit dieser remote extension
verbinden wir uns auf die man könnte das auch über einen terminal machen ja verbinden wir uns auf
unsere cloud vm und in der cloud vm haben wir proxy gesetzt wo wir ohne restrictions ins internet
kommen das heißt man kann tatsächlich mit dieser kombination arbeiten ich habe jetzt einfach nur
wishell studio code im fullscreen mein keyboard layout so gemapt dass ich terminal aufmache mit
einem shortcut und das geht ich habe jetzt ein terminal halt im fullscreen auf einer linux cloud
vm wo ich mehr oder weniger alles machen darf und ins internet komme also da kann man tatsächlich
arbeiten das ist das ist das ist tatsächlich ok so aber das windows notebook selber kann man
komplett in die tonne kloppen das ist hardware mäßig ganz gut ich meine das hat irgendwie
ein 8 core 8 core 8 intel 8 core ding so frag mich nicht was es für einer ist oder 6 core
keine art massig kurs für notebook und 16 g ram was auch ziemlich gut ist für notebook aber das
ist halt komplett versaut was die config angeht ich meine wer von euch musste schon mal auf so
einem super restriktiven windows notebook arbeiten ist ja der wird ja auch ein lied von singen können
dass man nicht wirklich was gescheites mit machen kann ja und jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir alle
cloud vms und können darum wursten wie wir wollen oh leute bei mir bei mir am haus fliegt
gerade eine AC 130 vorbei oder sowas in der richtung das ist keine AC 130 aber es fliegt
was mit propeller vorbei und es fliegt recht niedrig und es sieht aus wie eine AC 130 von
weitem also niedrig da sind wir noch ziemlich klein und hoch aber nicht so hoch wie normalerweise
die flieger hier vorbeifliegen er fliegt aber Richtung frankfurter fluchhafen ist keine AC
130 sieht aber so aus das ist wahrscheinlich so eine bundeswehr AC 130 keine ahnung warum
die nach frankfurt gerade fliegt das muss ich jetzt mal machen das kann ich so selten drücken
also es war es war irgendwas klobiges irgendwas klobiges mit propellern
lull 16 gigabyte ram sind standard in der it wir haben mindestens 32 gigabyte lull
ich bezweifle dass 16 g standard sind für den durchschnitts user aber hauptsache lull
lull leute
aber es könnte sogar 32 g ram sein ich bin jetzt gar nicht so sicher
die alten vielleicht waren auch die alten 16 in den neuen 32 ich weiß nicht aber lull
soll ich mal gucken ob 16 oder 32 sind ich habe es draußen im rucksack liegen ich kann jetzt
gerade nicht gucken so jetzt haben wir hier geupdatet update update update das ist geupdatet
das ist geupdatet jetzt muss ich noch die config files updaten ich bin mir gerade gar
nicht sicher wie man das macht so ne benutzt diesen config manager zu selten cd geht pull
das hoffentlich hoffentlich ab update alter was für dummes zeug schreibt man hier tab master
moment ich habe lokal sachen committed your branch is ahead of origin das zeigt einfach
nur müll an ok ich bin ich bin wie geht das mit dem konfig manager immer ich werde das
immer update 28 april ja ist richtig status ok update wir über bügeln einfach mal alles
has changed override bam override override ok nice ok so
und jetzt installieren wir noch die neuen cursor und dann sind wir ready to go
also mein neuer cursor ist natürlich enorm wichtig leute der maus cursor hier ist outdated
overrated she baited jetzt gibt es gibt jetzt neue maus cursor
pass auf wie gut gleich gibt's poggers maus cursor
viel besser als einfach so ein publischer schwarzer oder weißer kringel da
jetzt gibt's orangene mauszeiger abgerundete vector grafisierte
orangene mauszeiger guck hier bam
war das der flieger
oder soll ich das achso da ist ein bild dabei
das könnte tatsächlich war da mal war da mal war da mal wo ist
ok leute das müssen wir jetzt mal checken ob das ob das der flieger war sekunde das interessiert mich als war das mal kurz ich mache das mal macht mal auf
das interessiert mich jetzt
könnte es also von der optik es ist das eine AC 130 aber es sah so ähnlich aus
ist das in der nähe von hanau vorbeigeflogen würzburg
das kann eigentlich nicht sein
ausliegt das kann eigentlich nicht sein
falsche richtung das kann der eigentlich nicht gewesen sein
also selbst wenn er vorhin hier vorbeigeflogen ist also den hätte ich nicht so nahe gesehen bei mir kann der
eigentlich nicht gewesen
gibt es doch eine andere
aber ich finde es immer wahnsinnig interessant das hier rumguckt guckt euch das mal an frankfurter flughafen man
frankfurter flughafen geht gut was
naja
so viele sind das nicht
naja ich gehe mal davon aus dass dort nur die sachen angezeigt werden jetzt gerade gelandet sind oder demnächst losfliegen und alle die rumstehen nicht
naja
ich mein vielleicht war es auch das ding keine ahnung aber ich glaube nicht dass ich das so gesehen hätte an der stelle wenn das jetzt den mannheim schon ist
gut so leute habt ihr gesehen neuer mauszeiger am start hier beste
essential
ja
ich kenne mich damit nicht so aus aber es hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert wenn die einfach random alle anzeigen
muss ja irgendwie muss ja irgendwie sinn machen
moin beiß
ja wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben gerade
ich habe alles geupdatet haben wir wirklich alles geupdatet ja alles geupdatet und was wollte ich jetzt noch machen
wollten wir jetzt schon anfangen habe ich nicht noch gesagt ich erzähle euch noch was
reboot habe ich reboot schon gemacht abtime ja ich habe schon rebooted eindeutig
linux mint ja heute nicht heute nicht weiter oder vielleicht können wir das ganze auch unter
linux mint machen das wäre auch eine möglichkeit wir müssen uns glaube ich nämlich in ubuntu
installieren ich habe rebooted für den cursor genau jetzt haben wir einen ordentlichen cursor
wie findet ihr den denn? wie findet ihr den schlecht? achja und und ich habe ein cooles
neues programm gefunden nämlich irgendwas mit look hieß das irgendwas mit look weil aktuell
verwendet mal verwende ich ja gerne alex appearance um so themes zu ändern colors
und und sonstige sachen das dumme ist nur alex appearance ist kaputt
deswegen habe ich jetzt was anderes gefunden und das finde ich eigentlich noch viel besser
nämlich irgendwas mit irgendwas mit look kurzes programm mit look
nwg look genau da ist es doch nwg look meine güle
so und damit kann man auch seine gtk themes und so was setzen wir müssen mal kurz gucken dass
wir mal einmal hier noch checken was wir ausgewählt haben der cursor ist mega nice so und jetzt waren
wir hier ng wie heißt das ding ns ach du scheiße man was wie heißt das was ich gerade installiert
nwg look man das ist nicht so verbackt wie elix appearance nur mit dem unterschied wir
müssen jetzt erstmal hier alles neu einstellen also widget widgets haben man orkis dark compact
ich meine wir können auch wir können auch flat remix blue dark solid nehmen ist eigentlich
wurscht so icon theme flat remix blue dark mouse cursor ember font ist wurscht hat es
hier eigentlich nichts geändert font others gibt es hier andere ok alles apply so jetzt können wir
jetzt können wir hier unsere das wieder löschen jetzt haben wir hier ein ordentliches
programm zum einstellen was nicht rumbug beim setzten des mauscursors zeigt euch noch mal
mauscursor immer noch gesetzt funkt noch alles nvg look ja der cursor ist richtig also wem das
orange nicht gefällt den cursor gibt es auch noch in weiß in schwarz ach quatsch nicht nvg
look ein bescheuerter name kann sich wieder keiner merken den cursor gibt es auch noch in
genau in schwarz in in eis ach ok ok also gibt es den schwarz den gibt es den weiß und das ganze
gibt es noch mal in classic classic hat keine abgerundeten ecken ich persönlich finde die
kombination am besten alias du hast recht ohne mist es ist eine mega gute idee alias einzuführen
weil ganz ehrlich ich werde ich werde es mir nicht merken können ich werde immer alex appearance
eingeben alex habe ich das jetzt richtig geschrieben
apa apa was apa ranze apa ranze ok excellent ok dann zeige ich euch heute mal
hab ich doch gerade gemacht guck hab ich auch gemacht gut also dann zeige ich euch mal was
wir heute vor haben beziehungsweise was ich mir vorgenommen habe ob das dann klappt das müssen
wir mal gucken ich habe ja vor einer weile mein vm champ tool ge open sourced beziehungsweise
wir haben den kram ja hier zusammen im stream auch zu nicht unerheblichem teil entwickelt also es war
von anfang an ja so aus das ist ein programm womit man lokal zum testen vms starten kann
ja thomas geht um dein issue genau da ist er ja wir müssen erst mal raus kriegen woran das liegt
erst mal raus kriegen woran das liegt und noch vielleicht ein paar andere sachen einbauen die es
einfacher zu benutzen zu benutzen machen unter unter ubuntu ja wir müssen wir müssen mal gucken
ob wir auch rauskriegen woran es liegt so also nicht spoilern falls du schon geguckt hast ja
das ist sonst habe ich kein content heute abend mehr wenn du das jetzt spoilers
das das muss ja nicht sein du wolltest als fix art sind wir fixen das jetzt wir fixen
das jetzt für für jubantu wird das jetzt gefixt er hat übrigens schon der tom hat
schon exakt die richtigen den richtigen hausnamen für sein ubuntu guck mal guck
mal wie sein hausname heißt ich suche gerade mein ubuntu genau muss das ja aussprechen wie
die coolen leute ja also dann aber kurz zur erklärung das ist ein tool womit man easy
vms starten kann lokal ja dann sagt man zum beispiel vm champ run test vm 420 was auch immer run
und dann startet eine lokale test vm in dem fall standardmäßig die fault image ist debian hat
256 mb ram man kann das ganze allerdings auch überschreiben man kann auch sagen vm champ run
ja keine ahnung cpu willst du drei kerne haben und ram willst du irgendwie einen gig haben und du
kannst sogar sagen os oder kannst du dann auswählen zwischen kannst du ganz kannst du ganz aktuelles
ubuntu verleihen leute wir können es jetzt richtig high IQ meta meta machen wir können vm champ in
vm champ testen wobei das geht nicht wegen nested virtualisierung ich habe nested virtualisierung
nicht eingeschaltet was eigentlich auch eine gute sache ist weil es vielleicht nicht so sinnig das
nested zu virtualisieren zumindest ihr seht hier oben wir haben jetzt eine test vm am start und das
ging easy as fuck über die kommando zeile zackig und wenn man fertig ist sagt man vm champ clean oder
konnte man ja sagen purge oder clean was das firma als das firma als alias ein vm champ purge
ist glaube ich dass das erinnert die leute so ein bisschen an docker docker purge und so das machen
wir noch ein oh eine neue jet planes rider version ja dann zeigt doch mal her was gibt
verneuers bei rider key updates unity stellts number of lookups achso
ja wer shit in der ide verwenden beziehungsweise generell wer das über die ide macht der ist eh
lost also ich hab gelesen performance für das source control plugin nein es ist source
control für perforce meine gütte aber ganz ehrlich selbst wenn man git verwendet über so
eine ide das komplett für den arsch das einzig wahre ist git übers terminal ohne scheiß leute
ich mag keine egal welches ist es egal ob das die visual studio code get extension ist die
writer get extension die emacs get extension oder auch die wim get extension ich mag keine
wim ich mag keine git geschichten über ide zu machen das einzig wahre ist git über die
kommando zeile zu machen alles andere ist müll sage ich jetzt einfach so aber ich meine ist ja
auch so realtalk ich will jetzt keiner von abhalten dass nicht zockt zu machen ihr könnt
das machen wie es euch gefällt aber ich finde es unsinnig geht im editor geht über die kommando
zeile ist das beste github desktop alles müll ok vielleicht nicht vielleicht das nicht das
verwendet man unter windows alles was das leben unter windows ein bisschen erträglicher macht
soll mir recht sein aber ansonsten geht kommando zeile leute das ist das da wisst
ihr wenigstens auch was passiert und ihr wisst was geht unter der haube macht ich hatte mal
ein ex kollege auf der alten arbeit der hat immer dieses git plugin benutzt in eclipse falls
irgendjemand schon mal die ehre damit hatte das heißt ihr wisst ihr wie das heißt wisst ihr
wie das heißt das plugin das git plugin für eclipse das heißt e-git das sollte schon alles
sagen also da kannst du dir schon mal vorstellen wie viel das taugt und der name ist programm der
hat teilweise leere commits erzeugt und wusste dann nicht warum weil sein komisches eclips plugin
immer müll gebaut hat so wir finden es aber schnell in alias ein hier ich habe vergessen
wie das geht aber das machen wir ganz schnell das clean command kriegt ein alias alias alias
alias wie ging das noch mal hier this add alias ok clean command wo habe ich denn das hierhin
gemacht jetzt über ad argument gibt es ja nichts dann machen wir das hin ad alias da kann man sich
ganz gut merken ok so jetzt gucken wir uns mal das issue von ihm an was er hier aufgemacht hat
also das tool habe ich euch jetzt ja gezeigt gibt es gibt es noch irgendwelche questions weil ich
meine wir haben ja schon öfters an dem tool rum programmiert ich kann jetzt nicht jedes mal zehn
minuten da alles alles im detail erzählen also zumindest es ist ein tool dass man lokal schnell
zum testen vms anlegen kann besser als jetzt zum beispiel jedes mal eine neue vm durchzuklicken
klick klick klick hier und das neu anzulegen und halt für den fall der fette dass es in docker
container eben nicht rausreißt das wollte ich gar nicht dann also wenn es in docker container
nicht reißt dann könnt ihr den vm champ verwenden und wir müssen übrigens mal das
aktuelle ubuntu image runterlagen download ne moment mit welchem ubuntu hast du es gemacht
tom 22.10 oder ubuntu 22.10 kinetik kudu warum nicht 22.10 ok laden wir mal das aktuelle
ubuntu image runter und ja ich zeige euch jetzt noch einmal das tool in action während das
runterläuft ja ihr könnt zum beispiel auch ihr könnt dann auch mehr machen ihr könnt
nicht einfach nur sinnlosen debian vm anlegen wenn ihr jetzt zum beispiel sagt hey ich brauche
mal zum testen eine ubuntu vm dann sagt ihr einfach vm jam run hier test ubuntu muss auch
nicht test ubuntu heißen es kann auch irgendwie vm keckel chat oder was auch immer heißen sagt
ihr us ubuntu ihr seht autocomplete autocomplete und wir haben 22.10 nicht drinnen weil wir nur
die lts version drin haben wobei wir haben nicht nur die lts version drinnen 23 04 ist gar kein
lts gut aber nachdem er probleme hat gibt es die probleme höchstwahrscheinlich auch mit 22 04
so da kann man auch sagen disk immer 8 gigabyte disk und memory kriegt das ganze ding 2 gigabyte
zack boom starten er lädt sich das letzte cloud image runter und startet ein ubuntu
wunderbare geschichte gut wir machen mal alles zu hier
das hat das habe ich die ganze zeit gesucht so starts
alles klar wenn man einmal art space kennengelernt hat sagt obuntus kommt
halt darauf an wofür so ein bisschen so ein bisschen den einsatzzweck ja auf dem
desktop ja ist es so vor allem ein bisschen ahnung von nidox hat dann sagt
es sagt das richtig soll wir legen eine neue vm an guck mal das ist der
unterschied jetzt jetzt können wir uns live angucken schaut mal hier habe ich
zum test eine vm erzeugt und gut obuntu booted immer la guck zack das das das
hat jetzt das hat jetzt keine ahnung das hat jetzt 30 sekunden gedauert da
hatte ich eine neue obuntu vm am start guck ssh so zack also ihr seht wir haben
sie in der fonte wir haben hier eine vollwertige obuntu vm update so mein
normales system ist ja arch seht ihr ja hier pac-man bla sonst was also
eindeutig arch moment warum gibt schon wieder es gibt schon wieder ein update
ich habe vor fünf minuten geupdatet by the way aber aber hauptsache harfbass
updatet sich ich habe legit von der viertelstunde geupdatet warum ist schon
wieder neues update da so guck hier oben habe ich eine vm und das ist halt
offensichtlich in obuntu weil update und so ich kann auch kat etc issue euch
zeigen ja an a-a ihr seht das sind komplett unterschiedliche
parkisten da oben ist obuntu vm da unten ist mein art standungs und das geht
halt
saumäßig zackig über den vm champ alles anzulegen so und jetzt vergleicht
das mal mit mit dem was wir jetzt machen und zwar also 30 sekunden für den vm
anlegen und jetzt legen wir uns hier mal über die klassische art eine vm an
weil die brauchen wir jetzt gleich zum zum ausprobieren
linux obuntu 1 cpu vier kerne 8g ram bridge network connection das ist ok das
ist ok das ist ok 40 g disk sollte reichen single file next customized
hardware print daraus closed finish so edit da rein uefi einschalten da rein
nested virtualisierung einschalten jetzt können wir starten und während was
finished finished install achso ich habe das iso jetzt weiß was er für schmerz hat ich habe
das iso fürs ubuntu gar nicht eingelegt deswegen hat es nicht funktioniert hier
ubuntu desktop restart sollte er nicht jetzt von disk starten
disk install ubuntu ok
der name wäre ein bisschen zu unter der gürtellinie für meine vm vor allem wenn
ich das dann auch noch scheren irgendwie würde und auf einmal hätte ich dann das
im screenshot stehen wenn auch es einer gewissen wie soll ich sagen einer
gewissen es entbehrt nicht einer gewissen kreativität
ubuntu
da habe ich die soundkarte nicht eben entfernt
ich habe den drucke entfernt jetzt kriegen wir irgendwelche blöden ubuntu sounds gleich
weg install ubuntu
reboot wegen kernel update
du hast recht du hast recht reboot
auf jeden fall machen
so keyboard layout german das machen wir jetzt wirklich im schnell verfahren weil
eigentlich geht es mir hier nicht um die installation oder sonst was
no no dead keys next jawoll next
das andere ist rebooted max start x
ok wunderbar
habt ihr es gesehen leute
ubuntu scheint vmwartools standardmäßig mit zu installieren mittlerweile
massive massive stonks damit ihr jetzt nicht gerechnet warum macht das
warum macht das mint nicht wenn das sogar ubuntu macht
cringe das ding heißt kekel kekel vm
123456 massive best practice password
das ist wie bei fehlern leute guck mal wir programmieren nie fehler deswegen brauchen
wir keine tests brauchen keine kommentare und haben auch keine bugs
und das ist bei passwörtern das gleiche wenn man seinen rechner sicher macht kann man auch
123456 als password verwenden und trotzdem passiert nix einfach immer keine fehler machen
das ist die einfachste variante um probleme zu vermeiden merkt euch das just no error
das ist warum memory was das ist warum memory save languages ja siehst du genau ich weiß
gar nicht warum die so ein shit wie rust überhaupt erfunden haben raumann alles nicht
rust ist für die leute für die c++ zu schwer ist
genau dann dann alles direkt in seh ja
wobei warum z das ist doch hex editor warum sollte man mit so was billigem wie z anfangen
und auf den neuen festplatten mit einem laser und eine magnet direkt auf die direkt die disk
magnetisieren dass es dann wenigstens plaud vermieden
almost finished bin ich ja froh dass er almost finished ist das heißt gleich geht es los
auf jetzt mach fertig
Moment jetzt kommt erst installing system ich dachte der war copying files das ist schon
das install system nope wir müssen irgendwann mal Ubuntu 23 04 noch mal auf die schnelle
installieren um uns den neuen installer anzugucken weil das ist so ziemlich das einzige
neue nennenswerte was es für Ubuntu 23 04 gibt der rest ist langweilig das ist total
unbedeutend aber der installer ist angeblich neu der neue ist buggy ja das hat mich das würde
mich auch wundern wenn ich die waren bestimmt so sehr beschäftigt die leute wieder mit
irgendwelchen snap packages voll zu kacken anstatt den gescheiten installer zu bauen
jetzt habt ihr es langsam verstanden alles andere ist bloated
einfach aufs wesentliche konzentrieren und bloat vermeiden
war es das war eines der besten sachen an an an ubuntu dass es zfs integriert hatte
es kann doch gar nicht sein oder
alter was ist denn mit canonical los anstatt ihre distribution besser zu machen machen sie
sie immer beschissener also mal seriously ich hatte den eindruck auf dem desktop nicht unbedingt
auf so sehr auf dem server in in in in einem business cloud umfeld ich hatte den eindruck
damals so mit den ersten paar ubuntu versionen gerade noch als es kompets war kompets mit
irgendeinem gnome damals noch dass das wirklich der desktop der zukunft ist und mittlerweile ist es
neues gnome was von haus aus schon sagt und jetzt noch nicht einmal zfs was sind das für
ein müll was machen die denn eigentlich
ja hauptsache sie haben einen neuen installer aber zfs rausgeschmissen
warum sagt genommen weil es zum beispiel standardmäßig meine minimieren knopfe
fenster haben das ist wirklich
ok aber es ist wenigstens noch über die manuelle variante möglich ok restart nice
so ja ja wir remove das installationsmedium wir starten neu mal alles was ihr wollt installer
let's go dann sagt i3 aber auch gibt es keine minimieren knöpfe naja bei i3 i3 sagt aus
anderen gründen aber i3 ist eigentlich wirklich away was wollen die hier von mir so so away
ahead da kann man gar keine anwendung minimieren und wenn man keine anwendung minimieren kann
braucht man natürlich auch kein minimieren knopf aber unter Ubuntu kann man anwendung
minimieren und da Gnome kann man anwendung minimieren und die haben keinen minimieren knopf
aber wenn wenn der desktop erst gar nicht minimierbarer fenster support dann ist es ja logisch
dass es kein minimieren knopf gibt also macht die drei komplett richtig und Gnome falsch
was wollen die hier eigentlich von mir skip nein alter geht mir nicht auf den sack sind wir hier
ist ja fast so schlimm wie mir noch 11 im installer ok terminal habt ihr es gerade
gesehen ist es euch was aufgefallen leute
ne ich glaube ihr habt es alle nicht gesehen ich glaube ihr habt es alle nicht gesehen
ich benutze zu viel windows wisst ihr was ich gerade eingegeben habe um das terminal
zu starten ich habe gerade eingegeben cmd um das terminal zu starten wo sind wir denn hier
gelandet das windows notebook echt hat sich schon ins ins ins brain eingebrannt cmd man das würde
ich normalerweise nie freiwillig starten cmd auf der arbeit naja aber ich habe zumindest ein
paar command line fenster unter windows in letzter zeit gestartet wegen meinem crappy
verkonfigurierten müll restriktiven windows notebook so haben wir es doch geschafft so
also ubuntu ist am start wir müssen mal ein paar sachen installieren dass da vm champ
funktionieren kann als erstes muss ich erstmal sicherstellen dass ich per ssh
hier sachen drauf kopieren kann so if konfig das ist als erstes ist es lieber mal if konfig ich
weiß ip add und ip link und so und zeug aber leute ich kann es mir einfach nicht richtig merken
es liegt daran weil ich von anfang an if konfig verwende und so lange es if konfig gibt werde
ich weiter if konfig verwenden so ab install ab install open ssh server server mann so
system ctl start ssh enable ssh gut haben die western mittlerweile
ne glaube ich net ob nicht dass sie das standardmäßig drin haben ne das hätte
mich jetzt auch gewundert sondern starten wir das ubuntu einmal neu jetzt sollten wir
uns per ssh auf der ubuntu kiste einloggen können hätte ich mir die ip gemerkt habe
ich aber net pepega time hat also jemand von euch die ip gemerkt von dem ding
bin mir gar nicht sicher ob ich die ip überhaupt schon mal gezeigt habe
ubuntu hallo
ubuntu
hallo ist es jetzt kaputt
ist es ist es irgendwie kaputt oder so warum
warum ist es jetzt kaputt noch eigentlich nichts gemacht aus als neu gestartet ok jetzt geht's
was auch immer das gewesen ist ich weiß es nicht so terminal alles klar ok
if konf tatsächlich nice so ssh heckle add yes 123 56 ok nice also haben wir die ip dann
können wir das doch jetzt ausprobieren gehen wir hier rüber machen hier den browser auf
restore die letzte session machen einen terminal auf machen unsere ide auf und dann können wir
anfangen was bin ich eigentlich der einzige der es lustig findet dass mein ehemaliger praktik ja
wahrscheinlich weil du der einzige hier bist der ein praktikum da gemacht hat was das mein
ehemaliger praktikums mit jegliche ledigungsversion zum download bereitstellt und in zb leban als
download target angegeben wird ja du bist wahrscheinlich wirklich der einzige das lustig
findet weil wir haben ja da kein praktikum gemacht dort wo ich meine ausbildung gemacht
habe der provider der hatte auch einen offiziellen debian mirror aber übrigens leute das habe ich
letztens doch ich kann es euch erzählen das findet man dann trotzdem nicht raus ich hab
es ja letztens gefeiert wisst ihr wisst ihr dass der provider pleite ist bei dem ich meine
ausbildung gemacht habe der ist vor vor frag mich nicht 23 jahren oder so ist der pleite
gegangen habe ich letztens erst gelesen aber die wurden dann von irgendeinem
glaub schweizer unternehmen oder so aufgekauft und und jetzt heißen sie anders und machen
weiter und keine ahnung aber ja die sind pleite gewesen ne das fand ich gut weil es ein scheiß
laden war das hat mich gefreut ist ja der grund warum ich da weg bin weil habe ich hab ich ja mal
ein video drüber gemacht das war das war der laden mit diesem team building workshop wo
sie uns wo sie uns so richtig abgefuckt haben mit
okay also alles gestartet ja genau ja das ist das das ist das video genau aber ich hab
dazu glaube ich sogar noch zwei drei andere videos gemacht also das ist so das ist du
ist was wir uns heute angucken anscheinend gibt es ein problem mit ubuntu nämlich wenn
der tom den vm champ ausführt dann gibt es folgende fehlermeldung domain config error
unsupported configuration unknown watch dog model it co und das versuchen wir jetzt mal
nachzustellen in der ubuntu vm dazu müssen wir aber gar nicht auf die ubuntu vm drauf
sondern können das per ssh machen so ssh kakel add yes als einloggen funst also ssh copy id
übrigens wer das nicht kennt ich zeige euch das jetzt mal normalerweise müsst ihr ja immer wenn
ihr euch per ssh auf eine kiste einloggen müsst ihr ein password eingeben so die meisten werden
wissen dass man ssh keys verwenden kann um sich einzuloggen dass man kein password mehr braucht
was auch noch die meisten wissen aber ich zeige es euch trotzdem ist dass man mit ssh copy id
sein default ssh key rüber kopieren kann und wenn man nicht weiß welchen ssh key man rüber kopieren
will kann man das auch kann man das auch hier angeben sagen wir zum beispiel ich will jetzt
ja ich weiß gar nicht welchen ich will will ich den hier wahrscheinlich ich will den hier rüber
kopieren und wenn ich das jetzt gemacht habe und das in ssh key ist den standard mich verwende dann
geht das einloggen direkt ohne key so also wo haben wir denn die aktuelle vm champ version
vorführeffekt das kann gut sein hier ist der aktuelle vm champ copy link we get
ok z mod plus x vm champ linux vm champ linux amd find run test vm yes ja ja ok ok
sieht schon mal ganz gut aus
ich habe ja noch gar kein kvm installiert und nix ich muss ich muss ja erst mal kvm installieren
ist ja noch gar nichts drauf ja ok das ist klar das aber auch was was wir einbauen können ok
ich mache mir mal so eine kleine kleine to do liste für heute also das erste ist abfangen
falls lib wird nicht installiert da können wir ja installiert ja komm wurscht egal ich
schmeiß das eh nachher raus so also lib wird nicht installiert fangen wir irgendwas abfangen
dann den tom error müssen wir auf jeden fall abfangen falls der gleich kommt ok sudo
abinstall installieren wir einfach den wirtmanager der installiert alles mit was man braucht
hast du tips für ssh alias
überleg gerade was ist ein guter ssh alias weiß nicht
keine ahnung ich meine ich nehme ach moment moment du meinst nicht wie man ssh aliasen
kann sondern irgendwelche shortcuts für für benahmung von host oder was meinst du jetzt
keine anders benutze ich nicht das einzige was ich meine ssh konfig eingetragen habe ist
multiplexing mode ja das das finde ich unsinnig ganz ehrlich das finde ich nicht sinnig erstens
man hat eine shell history zweitens du hast autocomplete also ja ich mein kann durchaus
sinnvoll sein ja ich will das jetzt gar nicht abstreiten es kommt bestimmt bisschen auf den
use case an aber dann würde ich lieber was mit einem fuzzyfinder machen irgendwie mit fzf so
so ein ssh wohin wollen sie sich connecten oder sowas also ich habe meine ssh konfig
habe ich diesen habe ich control port eingestellt und ssh multiplexing eingeschaltet dass der und
also auch ssh sessions dass er eben sich nicht jedes mal einloggen muss das schneller geht dann
habe ich ein paar ssh konfig mit wildcards drinne dass der für github den richtigen key nimmt und
für server in der unternehmensdomain den richtigen key nehmen wobei ich das jetzt nicht habe bzw.
auch nicht mehr brauche weil ich komme ja von daheim ich gehe auch von daheim nicht mehr nicht
mehr nicht mehr dran ja also dann habe ich dann habe ich einen eintrag dass alle azure kisten oder
hatte ich einen eintrag dass alle azure kisten eigentlich den azure key verwenden den man
nach generieren kann genau so schauen wir jetzt mal systemctl status status lib wird
lib wird ist running ok dann gucken wir doch mal was jetzt der vm champ sagt der vm champ sagt
continue yes aha ok das ist der tom error unsupported configuration unknown watchdog model itco
ok ich habe eine vermutung woran das liegt ich habe eine vermutung woran das liegt und zwar
vielleicht ist es jetzt relativ easy es gibt hier in der xml hier machine gleich und ich
vermute dass der machine type schlicht und ergreifend zu neu ist das heißt wir gucken
jetzt mal wenn ich wenn ich mit dem wirtmanager vm anlege was da standardmäßig drin steht
hallo new manual install linux 2020 forward jaja es ist egal ich benutze es doch eh nicht
0 customize after installation ok was steht da standardmäßig drinne q35 ach unten steht
das mit dem watchdog direkt drinne habe ich nicht gesagt dass du nicht spoilern sollst
das ist das wollte ich gar nicht anklicken ok unten steht was mit watchdog ach da
in das schmeißen wird es einfach raus oder wofür ist das überhaupt da ok wir testen
jetzt erstmal hier ok dann ändern wir wir ändern jetzt zwei sachen einmal die
forember version da habe ich nämlich schon gesehen dass das probleme macht
oh ich bin blöd jetzt habe ich jetzt habe ich das einfach details storage
ok so da machen wir zwei sachen also der standard der standard typ für die vm ist
nämlich eigentlich nur der so hatte der gerade q 35 genau so dann haben wir unten noch irgendwas
mit watchdog da habe ich wirklich keinen plan was es ist watchdog lip wird lass uns mal gucken was
das watchdog device lip wird model gibt es nicht model haben wir da irgendeine model
the required model attributes specify what's real what's recommended device amulet ok wir
nehmen das warum weil wenn red hat sechs das unterstützt mann dann wird das jedes x beliebige
andere betriebssystem unterstützen ich bin ich bin mir nicht sicher wofür es da ist wenn ich ehrlich
bin keine ahnung was soll ich sagen virtual hard for what can be guessed und was macht es
ist das sowas wenn der wenn die vm crash dass es dann automatisch neu startet oder
sowas vielleicht jemand ingren von euch ne ahnung wenn die vm hängt dann kann der
watchdog die reboot ach so was gut dann ist ja richtig was ich mir gedacht habe ok ja dann
probieren wir mal so aus ob das ob das schon reicht die den eigentlichen
fehler zu fixen so da können wir jetzt serious max high iq build script verwenden dass das
funktioniert öffnen in explorer leute ich finde das nie wo steht es dann open in file explorer
siehts jemand von euch weiß das ist das open in nee
path popup konnte das nicht mal open in file explorer ok ich will eigentlich nur gucken wo man
das ja wir können jetzt ein high IQ build script verwenden, nämlich wir gehen jetzt nach cd
home max repos vmchamp git status wobei wir machen keinen commit und sagen jetzt .slash build
build.sh 0.0.6 0.0.5 ist die aktuelle version, guckt hier vmchamp minus minus version 0.0.5
0.0.6 und bauen das damit let's go was das jetzt macht ist folgendes das ist ein build file ich
kann es euch mal zeigen während das läuft ist nicht so spannend zuzugucken ich zeige euch mal
was es macht das ist ein build script was der max gebaut hat also nicht ich sondern der mod check
max und zwar download er sich in cento s7 in einem docker container kopiert den source code rein und
baut die software in dem cento s7 docker container und am ende kopiert er das binary raus und warum
macht er das das liegt daran weil self contain kompilierte dotnet programme keine abhängigkeit
haben außer die libc version des systems auf dem sie kompiliert wurden und wenn ich das auf
meinem archlinux kompiliere dann läuft das ja auch fast nix weil mein archlinux ist so neu
und wenn irgendeine ältere libc library geht das nicht deswegen kompilieren wir das auf dem cento
s7 und das ist so alt das ist von 2012 oder so und wenn das geht dann können wir uns relativ
sicher sein es läuft einfach überall das ist tatsächlich eines der großen vorteile von go da
gibt es diesen ganzen scheiß net ja du machst go bild und das läuft rückwirkend auf jedem linux
also es sei denn du hast irgendwelche abhängigkeiten drum herum zu extern libraries aber ansonsten
läuft das wenn das uns selbst content go programm ist läuft das rückwirkend bis glaube ich linux
kernel 26 32 oder 26 36 oder sowas also das ist tatsächlich mega nice was go angeht
ok so wir haben den ganzen kram kompiliert der output liegt unter bild nicht
macht er nicht doch ach so scp bild vm champ und das ganze soll im target system so heißen
so schauen wir mal ob das jetzt alle unsere probleme schon behoben hat gucken wir mal yes
habe ich nested virtualisierung nicht eingeschaltet ich habe nested virtualisierung
nicht eingeschaltet ich kann ja moment wer macht auch cgo cgo brauchst du ja nur wenn du
irgendwelche interop geschichten machen willst zu c libraries normalerweise macht es doch niemand
an oder ich mein warum sollt warum hat es einen sinn das ist doch standardmäßig auch bestimmt
nicht an soll es standardmäßig an sein frage ich mich ernsthaft warum aber warum ist es die
fault mäßig an aber auch warum ist es standardmäßig an also was der sinn ich
mein das coole an go ist ja gerade dass es dass es self contained executables bauen kann
rückwirkend bis linux kernel 26 36 hast du eine idee hast du eine ahnung warum das
warum ist es standardmäßig anders erscheint mir jetzt irgendwie sehr unsinnig
so meine vm ist wieder da und ich hoffe dass wir jetzt nested virtualisierung haben
das not support steht wird type k
ääääh
warum nicht
wo wir das mal mit dem wirtmanager aus
ok new manual install bla bla ja linux
warum nicht normalerweise geht das doch mit nested virtualisierung ohne jegliche probleme
hallo das fenster geht noch mal zu was ist das ein linux 2020
next ja nex nex es ist eigentlich egal nex was
denai ok das funktioniert warum kann der vm champ nicht starten hyper visor type kvm ist
das irgendein vm ist das irgendein problem dadurch dass ich in dass ich über ssh drüber
drinne bin oder moment jetzt geht es jetzt ist ein anderer fehler ok
keine ahnung was das für ein merkwürdiger fehler war freund aber jetzt scheint es zu
funktionieren wir rebooten mal schnell und gucken ob es danach immer noch geht sehr sehr wird
weird champ
sieht das für euch sieht das für ubuntu irgendwie so aus als als reboote das gerade oder wie
und am arsch weg rebooted man
erst tut so als rebooted nicht und auf einmal einfach einfach geplatzt rebooted
was was hat denn ubuntu wieder verschmerzen gerade
was was hängt was hängt darum
musste man nicht reboten auf reboten auf nein nein wir sind nicht unter windows da
musst du reboten auf machen unter lehrung sagst du reboot und da rebooted auch instant
ok jetzt nochmal abchecken das ganze jetzt ok also wir haben einen anderen fehler wir
haben jetzt einen fehler ok das ist aber das ist eindeutig irgendein ubuntu shit
lasst uns das mal kurz testen repos vm champ build vm champ und mal hier test vm lokal bei
mir und der arch funktioniert das ohne probleme und der debian wartet der eine minute bei
rebooten einen blödsinn macht er nicht erzählt den leuten nicht irgendwann erzählt den leuten
nicht irgendein blödsinn im chat mann der wartet keine minute unter debian soll ich soll ich euch
beweisen dass er keine minute unter debian wartet wir erstellen zufälligerweise gerade eine debian
vm die ich jetzt rebooten werde und ihr werdet feststellen wenn er dann irgendwann mal fertig ist
mit der vm erstellen werdet ihr feststellen nope das interessiert ihr nicht sudo reboot achtung
achtung bäm vm ist weg vm rebootet der wartet keine minute also also erzählt nichts reboot
ist unter linux instant was man machen kann ist und was vielleicht auch ganz sinnvoll ist
man kann sich zum beispiel also wenn man mal von programmen ausgeht die dabei sind ja kann
man zum beispiel sagen hat ein bisschen gebraucht einfach nur mit dem netzwerk also was ihr
zum beispiel installieren könnt unter debian ist das da gibt es das nicht mehr
ich muss erst mal update machen ich habe ja das ja noch das cloud image willst du das
neue zell auch ein bisschen stream nach stream wahrscheinlich nicht spielen werde ich auf jeden
fall ich habe bisher jedes zell gespielt selbst die ds teile so und wenn man jetzt sagt zu du
reboot dann sagt er guck mal nix mit reboot bist du dir wirklich sicher dass du rebooten willst
wenn du dir sicher bist dass du rebooten willst dann gib jetzt mal den name von der vm ein die du
rebooten willst also den lokalen vm namen also sprich jetzt geht das jetzt geht das nicht mehr
jetzt muss ich eingeben test vm und dann reboot der erst das kann man machen ich finde das
persönlich also auf dem system ist halt ganz praktisch da ist es dabei ich finde das ich
finde das sehr praktisch wenn das wirklich wichtige systeme sind dass man nicht ausversehen
rebooted und selbst wenn du normalerweise sudo nicht also wenn du normalerweise reboot machst
kann sudo davor dann geht es ja nicht aber oftmals hast du halt noch ein sudo davor in
der history stehen und hast vielleicht auch sudo vorher gemacht dann hast du es dann quasi noch
ohne password und zack hast du mal rebooted also ist mir auch schon passiert dass ich server
rebooted habe die ich nicht rebooten wollte deswegen unter debian finde ich dass tatsächlich hat
es seinen charm wenn man hier dieses wenn man das tool installiert dann muss man immer vom
reboot den namen eingeben oder selbstverständlich auch wenn man power off macht ja dann muss man
auch sagen power off hier beim champ clean wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen entspannendere
musik gerade was haben wir hier noch top 25 mario kart songs jawoll exzellent gut so also
tom dein fehler ist gefixt aber wir haben noch einen weiteren fehler und ich wette mit euch das
ist irgendein ubuntu besonderer ubuntu shit der ubuntu spezifisch ist kann ich wetten
so das müssen wir auch noch fixen also
ja tu du tom error tom error haben wir gefixt ubuntu netzwerk haben wir dann noch zelda stream
wäre schon als ich bin noch nicht so der krasse let's player ich weiß nicht ich finde das ich
denke das können andere wirklich besser ja aber thomas geht ja immer noch nicht ich habe ja
dein fehler ist weg aber der aber irgendwie komischer netzwerkfehler ist da da müssen
wir erst mal rauskriegen woran denn das liegt
ubuntu netzwerkfehler woran liegt der ubuntu netzwerkfehler leute was was was könnte der
für schmerzen haben
naja gut wir machen mal das was man immer macht in solchen fällen und suchen da einfach
mal danach
missing bridge konf no bridge konf by default access denied ich sehe schon ubuntu ist mal
wieder komplett auf usability ausgelegt was solche sachen angeht und es funktioniert schon
ja bruh was ist das hier bridge networking yo
was macht der für dinge alter das werde ich bestimmt nicht unter der haube ausführen was
etc qemo bridge config das das file etc yes ok
wie sagt bloß die datei gibt es nicht tatsächlich
ubuntu bringt keine vm bridge mit die habe ich eben angelegt deswegen gibt es hier eine
ja warum denn das nicht warum hat dann ubuntu für vms keine standard bridge dabei was ist das für
den blödsinn warum hat ubuntu den bridge schon keine standard bridge mäßig dabei für vms
ok ip link sets wir brüllen du musstest du das tom musstest du das auch manuell anlegen
gut ich meine das ist ja nicht schwer das können wir ja machen das können wir ja machen das ist
ja kein ding so echo mk dir etc qemo echo 0 nach bridge und jetzt ist es jetzt da ok
probieren wir noch mal was er jetzt macht yes yes ah fuck
oh das ist jetzt ein anderer fehler user lip ku emu ku emu bridge helfer helfer operation
alter wie beschissen ist das bitte schön bei ubuntu hier was macht der da
sui die noch setzen darauf
und jetzt jetzt gehts meine güte also wie beschissen ist das unter ubuntu vorkonfiguriert man das ist ja
komplett unusable das kannst du eigentlich keinem zumuten dass du das noch machen musst vor
allem wenn es so aussieht als würde das alles funktionieren aber es funktioniert halt nicht
kurze frage ist das normal dass wenn man software updates macht sich die vm zerschießt ne das ist
nicht normal kde aber durch kde sollte sich nicht die vm zerschießen sondern halt im schlimmsten
fall kde nicht mehr starten leck wirklich was da los vor der faun o trop frames o o vor der faun
was da los
ne moment falsche anbieter
wie wäre es mit snapshots von der vm machen das ist ja gerade das gute an vm
dass man snapshots snapshots machen kann moment du hast einen snapshot gemacht
dein snapshot funktioniert nicht mehr dann stimmt irgendwas anderes nicht wenn
du den snapshot zurückrollst das ist ja sogar der ram inhalt mit dabei
ja dann ist irgendwas das also wenn der snapshot zurückrollen nicht geht dann kann es auch nicht
an kde neo liegen ich habe kein ssh key, ssh key, keygen, ja ja alles gut hier
ok das war's das heißt ok das können wir einbauen das können das das das können wir
tatsächlich einbauen also den tom error haben wir gefixt so da gehen wir mal nach helper hier
ist nämlich das zeug drinne wo der unter der haube die bridge anlegt
lasst uns mal gucken ob das wieder vor allem überhaupt jetzt funktioniert
waiting for network
postchamp
das dauert schon erstaunlich lange
jetzt müssen wir nur noch einbauen
jetzt müssen wir nur noch einbauen, dass es auch immer funktioniert
also das heißt wir
löschen jetzt noch mal die bridge
del bridge
rm, etc, qemu
bridge
ok wir müssen unser
unser bash script was das macht ein bisschen
ein bisschen erweitern
wer von euch ist high iq chat
wer von euch weiß wie man in bash checkt ob eine datei existiert
also ich vermute mal irgendwas mit test
aber sicher bin ich mir da aus dem kopf nicht
file exists
ok so
file exists minus f
test minus f ist es
test minus f ja oder oder in bash
äh eckige klammer
hey max hast du in deinem neuen pc wasser und luftkühlung kombiniert?
ja hab ich
die cpu ist wasser gekühlt und die grafikkarte und das netzteil sind luftkühlt
äh file exists sowas gibt es in bash? nee oder?
nee hätte mich auch gewundert chat was schreibt ihr da wieder für komisches zeug?
also test minus f wir probieren das jetzt mal so aus
php?
zum teufel kommt ihr auf php? sieht das hier in irgendeinem hart und fall wie php aus?
wie keine wasserkühlung fürs netzteil ja cringe ich weiß
richtig, richtig cringe
ok also if, machen wir mal so, if test minus f etc cool ist, dann machen wir das mal so
atc qemu, bridgeconf ist das denen glaube
wenn die datei nicht existiert dann
wollen wir folgendes machen
dann wollen, was wollen wir dann überhaupt machen? Dann wollen wir auf jenemfall schonmal mkdir etc qemu machen
das kann man durchaus, das ist ja nicht schlimm, das kann man durchaus unter der haube machen
ich habe vorher frage ob die bridge angelegt werden soll
dann machen wir touch auf die datei
dass es die gibt
wobei wir uns das wahrscheinlich sparen können, weil als nächstes machen wir
nämlich einen von den echo
und was muss da rein
echo
ja ne, das müsste eigentlich reichen
und jetzt machen wir die schleife zu
oder noch eskaten glaube ich
so
if not
file
etc qemo bridgeconf
then mkdir
ach so und dann brauchen wir noch habe ich ganz vergessen chmod
das da
so das will ich jetzt allerdings nicht ganz ohne irgendwelchen hinweis machen
das heißt wir schreiben jetzt die
meldung hier oben ein bisschen um
schreibe aus für die som
des 3
urschon ne das stimmt nicht das wort
was habe ich
des
ist das jetzt richtig
som distribution
tun not
ab
rich
hat sich geliebt ok
do you want to create one now
ends
allow
all vms
ich weiß nicht ob man das so schreiben kann aber ja
versteht man
wenigstens bisschen
du du du du
ich mag keine playlist die unterschiedlich laut sind
passt das jetzt so ergibt das Sinn
was ich hier gebaut hab
koemo bridge
ja ich denke
ich denke das ergibt Sinn
probieren wir mal aus ob es funktioniert
nein
Bild
006 und dann hinten dran direkt
was ist das SCP Kommando
total
total hängen geblieben hier das will ich machen
das will ich machen erst bilden und dann das ganze Ding rüber kopieren per SCP
und da gucken wir jetzt mal
ob das was gebracht hat
was wir hier gebaut haben
du du du du du du
Run
haben wir erstmal clean schmeißen wir wieder alles weg
alles weg
ich hoffe das klappt jetzt ich meine da müsst ihr eigentlich checken ist die
Datei da? Nein ist nicht da und dann anlegen und und
und das Bridge Interface starten also das
müsste eigentlich gehen, guck mal mal, Default Network Bridge, das Nord-Vorn
some distributions
do not set up a bridge automatically, do you want to create one and allow for
amps to use it, yes
following Default Network Bridge is going to be created, yes
cannot create, file exists, ja gut, soll mir recht sein
und warum hat er jetzt die Bridge nicht angelegt?
card etc qemo
das hat aber auch vorher, das hat auch funktioniert
ich weiß warum er es nicht angelegt hat leute
ich weiß warum er es nicht angelegt hat weil ich wahrscheinlich durch mein manuelles rum
gefricke habe ich wahrscheinlich noch ein übrig gebliebenes qemo network
ok wo ist jetzt wo ist das problem machen wir das ganze noch mal aus yes yes ach jetzt geht's
warum
habe ich irgendwas vergessen es ist immer verdächtig wenn sachen zweimal
braucht vielleicht ein bisschen die kommandos hier sind alle synchron wenn die fertig sind sind
fertig was hat er denn eben für was hat er eben für fehlermeldungen noch mal geschmissen
ok das hat funktioniert
ich meine ohne scheiß vielleicht brauchen wir wirklich ein sleep ich weiß wir machen
da mal ein sleep 2 rein ich bin mir da zwar jetzt gerade unschlüssig aber so dann duschen wir das
ganze mal wieder m down del bridge
löschen die vm so bridge ist weg run mal gucken ob das jetzt was bringt yes
fahrt was ist denn das
so wenn ich es jetzt nochmal mach gehts passt auf
wo sagt er der no such device wo kommt man das macht er beim anlegen der vm
ok da bin ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen überfragt was der für schmerzen hat
der sleep ist nicht im binary drin du hast recht lull hast recht er ist nicht drin ich
habe das ganze gar nicht neu gebaut wir machen übrigens mal 6 dass ich weiß welche version das
ist ja du hast recht das ist blödsinnig gewesen ist überhaupt nicht drinnen haben
das gleiche doppelt getestet unsinnig so also vor m jam clean es das löschen wir
so jetzt kompilieren wir das neu und in der zeit wo er das macht sagen wir noch mal down
vom interface m von der datei und die liebte bridge so und jetzt machen wir vor m jam minus
linux und jetzt hoffen wir dass es funktioniert manchmal manchmal muss halt ein sleep sein ich
hoffe das geht jetzt mit dem sleep container bild tree test for beste mühsamung
funktioniert weil ansonsten wenn es nicht geht habe ich keine ahnung woran es liegt
prägetime fack warum legt er das nicht an was ist das hier
als chat hat nicht mal präge geholfen
gut das legt aber an meinem hässlichen skript hier was nicht richtig funktioniert
ja das stimmt beiß aber das macht er standardmäßig auch der führt ja den hier nicht aus bevor der
hier fertig ist das geht ja der reihe nach das ist nur wenn ich das irgendwie in background schicke
was ich ja nicht mache. Es ist sehr merkwürdig dass es alles funktioniert. Leute ich muss mal
kurz meine die Sachen hinschreiben was da macht. Dass ich sehe was passiert. Ich bin jetzt echt
ein bisschen ratlos gerade. Ich muss noch eins weg machen, wo denn? Ah hier, ja, hast recht.
Abbrechen, abbrechen, noch mal neues Bild. Leute, ich habe heute auf der Arbeit mit Terraform
Kubernetes Klasse in Google aufgebaut über einen Jobrunner der in GitLab läuft. Ich hatte
kein eigenes Terraform auf der Kiste. Ich musste das immer, weil ich habe da nicht die ganzen
Berechtigungen, ich musste das immer über einen Push und dann über eine GitLab-Pipeline machen,
Leute. Ich sage euch, das war so abfuck langsam alles. Ich habe was geändert und habe 15 Minuten
gewartet bis ich gesehen habe, ob es funktioniert hat. Ich habe legit, ich habe den ganzen Tag dafür
gebraucht, ein GKE-Cluster aufzubauen, bis es dann am Ende so genau war, wie ich wollte. Anstatt
ein, zwei Stunden mit der ganzen Konfig, weil alles so unglaublich langsam funktioniert hat.
Okay, run test for M. Ja, extremely resident sleeper. Äh. Moment, Moment, Moment,
ich bin, ich bin blöde Leute. Ich hab vergessen das Zeug zu löschen. Daun, Del Bridge, RmQemu.
Kann das sein, dass es jetzt noch hängt, das Default Network? Ja, das Default Network ist noch,
ich glaube. Ich glaube, das ist das eigentliche Problem. Leute, ich vermute mal,
es funktioniert sogar alles. Ja, guckt mal, das ist das Problem. Es funktioniert eigentlich
alles. Ich hab bloß schlicht und ergreifend nicht alles gelöscht. Leute, jetzt wird's auf Anhieb
funktionieren gleich. Pass auf. Yes. Ja, es war alles richtig. Ich hab nur die Hälfte vergessen zu
löschen. Okay, nice. Wir sind verschleiern, dass sich alle Fehler schmeißen und ich nicht ordentlich
gebash-scriptet hab. Oh, perfekt. Okay, nice. Ja, dann hat's ja doch funktioniert. Können wir
das eigentlich auch ausmachen? So, da haben wir das gefixt. Dann kompilieren wir das noch einmal.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch, was ich machen wollte? Also, den Fehler vom Tom haben wir
gefixt. Das geht jetzt auch unter Ubuntu. Ich wollte noch gucken, ob LibVirt überhaupt
ready ist, wenn ich das erste Mal das Programm starte. Würde ich sagen, dann gehen wir hier
mal nach zu Interop und machen dort irgendeine Helperfunktion. Public, Static, Bool, Check.
Ich baue da einen guten Namen für. Check, LibWirt. Ist, ist, keine Ahnung. Installed. Sehr guter Name.
Okay. Return falls. Gut, wie checkt man das jetzt gescheit? Wie, wie checkt man ob? Okay. C sharp, DLL import, check if DLL exists. Ja. Check if DLL is present in the system. Ja. Übrigens lasst euch mal nicht von DLL, DLL, DLL schibaten und sowas. Das, das, das liegt noch daran, dass es früher von Windows DLL import heißt. Es geht für Linux-Libre.
Genau so. Check if a DLL is present in the system. Load lib, kernel 32 unter Linux. Ja. Ja, genau. Ganz Windows Gbader. Ist, das ist ne gute Idee. Is lib wird installed. Das wird gut. Trinken. Ja, ja. Der Nightbot ist wieder kaputt.
How to check if DLL. DLL Import Offline. Ich mein, okay. Wir können, wir können das ganz simpel machen. Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob das ne gute Idee ist. Also, wir können einfach sagen, unsave. Wobei. Ich bin mir gar nicht mal sicher. Okay, probieren wir mal aus hier. Unsave.
Interop. So, da knallts, da knallts jetzt ja gleich.
Connection Open.
Kackel.
Da knallts jetzt gleich.
Ich mein, wir könnten ein Try Catch drum herum machen.
Bumm.
Äh.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich brauch, Moment, Blödsinn.
Ich brauch irgendwas, was es nicht gibt.
Hier.
Blob.
Das da.
Okay.
Exzellent.
Äh Blob.
Okay, jetzt gibt's Fehler.
Kann der Chat mich aufklären, was er da problemiert?
Ich bau an meinem VM-Champ-Tool.
Und zwar gibt es einen Bug unter Ubuntu.
Den wir übrigens gefixt haben.
Und auch ein paar andere Sachen für Shit-Ubuntu-Default-Config eingebaut haben.
Damit kannst du testweise VMs anlegen bei dir.
Besser als über irgendwelche GUIs.
Weil normalerweise musst du den Installer durchklicken für 10-15 Minuten.
Und manchmal reichen Container auch nicht für das, was du testen willst.
Also wenn du lokale Test-VMs brauchst, kannst du einfach sagen
VM-Champ, Run, Blub, VM.
Schon lädt er sich ein aktuelles Debian-Image runter und startet dir lokal eine VM zum Testen.
Und wenn du fertig bist, also der bootet jetzt die VM und verbindet sich dann per SSH drauf.
Das dauert so 20 Sekunden, 15 Sekunden, 20 Sekunden.
Dann ist er auf der VM.
Versus viertel Stunde mit Installer oder 5 Minuten mindestens mal mit Installer durchklicken.
Und du kannst dann nachher rückstandslos wieder die ganze Sache entfernen.
Das ist für alle Sachen gut, wo du was ausprobieren musst in irgendeinem isolierten Environment, wo Container es nicht tun.
Zum Beispiel wenn du Kernel-Module brauchst oder Systemd, Unit-Files testen willst oder sowas.
Das geht alles in Docker-Container nicht gescheit.
Dann sagst du einfach VM-Champ, VM-Champ, Clean.
Und wir machen dann noch...
So, okay, das gibt es nicht. Kann man diese Dinger einfach Try Catchen?
Das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert. Try Catch.
Cake Wait.
Ja, geht. Easy.
Machst du noch Emojis rein? Habe ich doch schon.
Ich habe doch schon jede Menge, jede Menge Emojis drin.
Wie du hier siehst. Guck, da, da und da und auch ganz viele Emojis.
Okay, das ist natürlich die Noob-Variante. Ich weiß nicht, ob die so geil ist, aber die funktioniert.
Einfach einen Try Catch drumherum machen.
Ich meine, das ist wirklich, das ist wirklich die simpelste Variante, glaube ich.
Auch wenn mir die nicht wirklich gut gefällt, aber gibt es, gibt es da nichts anderes?
Kannst du nicht einfach die installierte Version abfragen? Nö, ich wüsste nicht wie.
How to programmatically check?
Frag doch Chat-GPT. Ich bin gerade nicht eingeloggt. Ihr könnt aber fragen.
Prilink. How to programmatically check?
File exists? Das ist für einen Schwachsinn.
File exists ist... Alter, sowas ist eine Antwort.
File exists? Alter, die sind hängen geblieben bei Microsoft, Mann.
Schell-Commands abfragen.
Ja, aber ich mein...
Nein.
Was willst du mir sagen, GripperFox?
Mach da mal einen ordentlichen Satz raus, ich versteh nicht, was du mir sagen willst.
Ja, ich will checken, Max, ich will checken, ob...
...ob es das Ding hier gibt.
Ob es, ob es, ob es das gibt.
Da muss es doch irgendwas anderes geben, außer versuchen zu importieren und das dann abzufangen, oder?
Da muss es doch irgendwas, irgendwas Gescheites geben.
Du kannst importieren und zum Beispiel die Version auslesen.
Ich kann es aber doch nicht importieren, weil es die vielleicht nicht gibt.
Das ist doch gratis. Ich will gucken, ob es sie gibt, bevor ich die importiere.
Load Library
Ok, C-Sharp Load Library
Ey, ich will kein Bash-Commando dafür aufrufen, das muss doch auch so irgendwie funktionieren
Da gemm ich mich nicht so mitzufrieden, Leute
Das da muss ich wette mit euch, da gibts was, da gibts garantiert was, ich bin bloß zu blöd dafür danach zu googlen
runtime, oder vielleicht sollten wir mal suchen nach dynamic, dynamic load oder sowas
ja, irgendwelche c++ sachen bringen mir doch nix, das ist doch alles Mist
ja, lass mal bei Bill Gates klingeln
DLL import dynamic
native library load, wo hast du denn das jetzt gefunden?
guck mal, try load, das ist doch genau sowas was ich brauche hier
native library try load, meine güde, das ist ja so krass versteckt hier immer
native, ok proben wir mal, na einen moment, native overlapped, what?
native library try load, keckel, ja das gibt's net und jetzt, ah, var out handle
sag mal, wo hast du das denn her jetzt? wo hast du das denn jetzt gefunden?
äh, ah, falsch rum, ok, handle gleich gleich in pointer zero,
schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert, also das sollte jetzt ja eigentlich,
ok, es, das sollte jetzt ja eigentlich true rauskommen, ja ok, ok, nice, nice, nice,
so und jetzt, wenn ich da was reinschreibe, was es gibt, dann sollte da hoffentlich falsch rauskommen,
nice, easy, native library, try load, da wäre ich ja, da hätte ich jetzt noch lange googeln können,
was sich wieder bewahrheitet, der chat ist einfach besser als chat gpt,
ich wette mit euch, chat gpt hätte es auch nicht gewusst,
jetzt gucken wir einfach, if handle gleich gleich in pointer zero, äh ungleich zero,
dann hat es funktioniert und wenn das nicht funktioniert hat, dann schmeißen wir eine
Fehlermeldung. Also gucken wir jetzt einfach mal, if ist installed, if not installed, dann sagen
wir in rot. Okay, mal testen, ob es funktioniert. Ich gebe mal einen Fake ein. Oh fuck, ich sollte
noch einen Return reinschreiben. Ich kann nur... Lul. Lipp wird noch ein Found. Bam. Sehr schön.
Nice. Genau so, wie es sein muss. So gefällt mir das. Ja, gut. Sehr schön. Dann können wir
das ja nochmal bauen jetzt. Mit der Abfrage drin. So, da haben wir doch eigentlich alles gefixt,
oder? Sehe ich das falsch? Nö, so eigentlich alles durch. Lipp wird install. Lipp wird noch ein
Found. Ja, passt doch. Ist doch gut. Dann können wir jetzt eine neue Version raushauen, würde ich
sagen. Easy. Also Tom, kannst ja gleich mal ausprobieren, ob es funktioniert. Ich haue jetzt
eine neue Version auf ins Art User Repo und in das Release auf GitHub. Kannst du noch das
neue Demian 12 Image hinzufügen? Ja, das kann ich machen. Wenn es da schon zum Download gibt.
Gibt es da schon zum Download?
Bookworm
Ah, Latest
Nee, kann ich doch nicht
Das gibt es nur als Daily Build
Es gibt ja noch kein Latest
Da müsste ich das später wieder ändern
Wobei
Eigentlich nicht, ja doch, komm
Ich kann Bookworm
Dabei machen, warum nicht?
Die richtige Url ist dann
Latest so in dem Fall
Ja doch, machen wir
10, okay, Debian
Aber noch Debian 12
Debian 12, was wahrscheinlich auch so heißt
denke ich mal
Nein, heißt nicht so
Ach, Minus Daily
heißt das noch
Ja, gut, kann man ja machen
Minus Daily
Und es ist auf jeden Fall nicht Bullseye
sondern
Bookworm
Wer ist denn aus Toy Story der Bookworm
Toy Story Bookworm
Ist das der Grüne?
Ja, der
Ja, das ist der Grüne
Ist das der Grüne?
Ja, der
Warum ich nach Toy Story gucke ist
Die Debian Versionen sind alles Toy Story Charakter
Die Codenamen von den
Releases
Bullseye ist ein Toy Story Charakter
Buster, ich glaube Buster
Ist Buster nicht der Dinosaurier?
Der Hund
Buster ist der
Buster ist der Hund
Bullseye, wer ist das?
Ach, das Viech
Wie heißt der Dinosaurier
in Toy Story?
Rex
Ok, ich glaube
Debian Rex gab es noch nicht
Du hast noch die Toy Story geschaut
Also
Ganz ehrlich, der erste Toy Story
der hat ziemlich unter der Zeit
gelitten von der Grafik her, aber ich finde
es immer noch ein guter Film
So, gucken wir mal ob
Minus Minus OS
Debian 12
Das jetzt funktioniert
Sieht so aus
Debian Images werden runtergeladen
Ok, nice
Kunst
So, Debian 12 ist auch drin
Dann können wir das jetzt eigentlich pushen
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher
wie ich das gebaut habe
Für die
Für die Releases, das musste ich taggen
Glaube ich
Ja, ich musste es taggen
Und meine Action
Meine GitHub Action
Die ging auch dann auf
Pushed Tags
Genau, also Master kann ich pushen, das ist kein Problem
Ja, so
Cat, Etc, Issue, Debian
12, ok, hat funktioniert
Nice, sehr schön
Easy Clap
Git Status
Git
Commit A-M
Fix Shit, na komm
Fix Ubuntu
Edit Debian
Git Push
Master
Hab ich vorher nicht gepullt?
Ich hab vorher nicht gepullt
was hab ich denn
Ach Readme Updates hab ich vorher gemacht
Ok
Alles klar es gibt Schlimmeres
Ich hab Readme Updates verpasst
Na gut
Ok Push
Ach ich hätte Fick
Ich hätte Fix
Fix dabei schreiben sollen
Dann hätte nämlich
Automatisch
Das mach ich jetzt einfach nochmal
Äh
Fix
Ähm
Welches Issue ist das?
Neun
Und kann man das nicht einfach so schreiben?
Push
Boss
Ja
Issue geschlossen
Jetzt müssen wir noch eine neue Version veröffentlichen
Und ich glaube ich hab in meinem Buildscript
noch irgendwas blödes drin stehen
Was ich ändern wollte
Muss ich mal kurz reingucken
Ich wollte noch irgendwas anpassen hier drinnen
Also
Das ist eine GitHub Action
Also das ist eine GitHub Action
Die läuft jedes Mal wenn ich in Tag pushe
Und die baut die Software
Quasi das gleiche
Wie wenn ich hier lokal mit dem Buildscript
in dem Docker Container das baue
Nur dass es den Github Cache noch benutzt
Dass die Builds schneller gehen
Und
Am Ende
Push noch einen Arch User Repo Package
Und ich glaube
Dieses Arch User Repo Package Ding
Das muss ich nochmal
Das muss ich nochmal fixen
Und zwar
Guck nochmal, es gibt nämlich so ein kleines
kleines Problem
Git pull
Es gibt so ein kleines Problem nämlich
Ich muss mal kurz
ehm
OM
OMChamp
Die ganzen
Krempel löschen
So
Es gibt nämlich ein kleines Problem hier in
meinem Arch User Repo
Ich hab das letzte Mal um das Bild zu fixen
das Package Release
hochgezählt so
Und das Package Release
Das habe ich in meinem
Github Build gar nicht drinne
Das heißt das Package Release ist jetzt
immer auf Version 2
Das wird gar nicht mehr überschrieben, das muss ich mal gucken
ob ich das irgendwie gefixt kriege
So tun wir mal so
als würden wir
Version 6 bauen
Was stimmt an meinem Seht nicht
Was
wo ist man Seht hin
Ah ich habe ein Leerzeichen davon
Was ist die Frage
Was ist das
Wait
Was stimmt an meinem Seht nicht
染?
Im Package Version
Was ist an meinem Seht verkehrt
Package Version
Sieht
Muss ich das vielleicht Quoten
Ich hätte es Quoten
Müssen
Seie
Ich habe
ich habe das aber auch
nicht gequoted
Ich lasse mal so
Okay jetzt muss
Wie mache ich das jetzt am besten
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß
Also Moment
Je nachdem
Ich weiß es gibt es komplett fix und fertig
Das ist aber nicht Sinn und Zweck das sage ich
Ich überlege gerade, wie man das selbst machen kann
Also das ist ja easy, hier wird immer der Tag eingesetzt
Aber wie mache ich denn das Ganze jetzt
Für die
Für das Package Release
Das Package Release ist ja nicht anhand der
Comets wirklich
Das Package Release ist
Das muss nicht zwangsläufig
Anhand der Comets sein, ich kann ja auch 5 Comets
Machen und dann einen neuen Tag
Und dann ist es nicht automatisch Package Release 5
Sondern Package Release 2
Also
Okay, von der Logik her
Ist es doch so, wenn die
Package Version gleich der
Package Version ist, die gepusht wird
Dann will ich eins hochzählen
Oder? Okay, das, das, das
Das testen wir jetzt mal
Das wird jetzt, das wird jetzt ein bisschen ekliche Bash Magic
Aber ich hoffe, ich hoffe es funktioniert
So, machen wir hier
Version 0.0.5
Zum Beispiel
So, also
Gucken wir mal
Crap Package
Oh, das wird ekliches Bash Leute, ich sag's euch
Äh
Version
In PKG Bild
So, hat er gefunden
Okay, if, if das
Ach du Kacke
Ähm, jetzt muss ich if hier
If
Okay, wenn er, wenn er die Package Version
Findet
Dann will ich, okay da weiß ich nicht aus dem Kopf wie es geht
Dann will ich das Package Release einzu-
Leute, ich muss mal kurz Minibash
Skript dafür bauen, sonst, sonst
Check ich's grad nicht
Das kommt aber auch gleich wieder weg
Das ist nur zum hier
Testen.sh
Bin
Bash, also was ich jetzt probiere
Probiere ist folgendes
Guck mal, in diesem
In diesem Release File steht drinne
Package Version
Und Package Release
Package Release
Wenn ich jetzt ein neues Release pushe
Und die Package Version
Eine andere ist, als die, die drin steht
Dann ist das Package Release
eins, genau ligat
Wenn ich die gleiche Version pushe
Wie hier schon drin steht
Dann Package Version eins hochzählen
So, also
Heißt im Endeffekt
Probieren wir das
Mal aus
Test.sh
So, if
So, Version ist jetzt
Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt nur
Für mich zum checken
Das kann man nachher in der GitHub Action nicht so machen
Also, wenn Version
Gefunden wird in der Datei
Dann will ich, ja hier
Increment der Dings
Ansonsten else
Ansonsten, das else ist einfach
Seht, Package Release
So, und wie zähle ich
Das ganze jetzt hoch?
Boah, das wäre eklig
Weil ich weiß ja nicht, was für eine Package Version da drin steht
Wie kriege ich jetzt
Aus dem Package Build
Package Release 2
Ok
Cut
Am Gleichheitszeichen
Und dann das zweite Feld
So, und das
So, und das muss jetzt
Eins hochgezählt werden
Also jetzt wollen wir quasi
Wie war das Bash Rechnen?
Da bin ich zu blöd für
Das kann ich mir immer nicht merken
Ne
So muss ich das jetzt machen
Es geht
Aus dem Kopf Leute
Kann man das nicht noch ein bisschen vereinfachen?
Das checkt doch keiner
Alter
Das ist ja abartig
Rell
Ok
Rell ist entweder das
Oder Rell ist eins
So
Rell gleich eins
Wir machen es einfach so
Da kann ich mir das L sparen
Ähm
Und das wird
Ersetzt
Durch
Rell
Und wir machen jetzt mal das Minus
I weg
Ok jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Source Package Build
Nee das wird doch
Nichts bringen
So testen
Ok es ist Package Release 3
Weil wir pushen die gleiche Version
Wir pushen eine andere Version
Dann sollte Package Release 1 sein
Ok es funktioniert was wir gebaut haben
Nice
Jetzt müssen wir das bloß noch in unser GitHub Action einbauen
Moment warum mach ich das über den GitHub Editor
Ok
GitHub Workflow Build
So das müssen wir jetzt irgendwie in unser GitHub
Skript einbauen
An welcher Stelle denn hier
Hier muss das eingebaut werden
Ah weg
Ok if
Gewohnheit von der Arbeit
Was denn
So
Package Version
Ich bin nicht ganz sicher ob das passt
Was ich hier mache
Also Version gibt es ja
Achso im GitHub Editor ja das kann durchaus sein
So
Jetzt muss ich sagen
Release gleich eins
So
Also jetzt ist es nicht mehr Dollar Version an der Stelle
Sondern es muss sein
GitHub Ref
Weil da steht nämlich die
Tech Nummer drinne
So ich hoffe Version benutze ich nirgends
mehr
Ne mach ich nicht
Es muss jetzt First Try funktionieren Leute
First
First Try
So Package Release
Minus I
Also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ich glaube ich muss es nicht
Quoten
Weil alles andere
Wird hier auch nicht gequoted
So das ist
Wichtig dass ich das zum Schluss mache
Also was denkt ihr?
Meint ihr es funktioniert jetzt?
Also Release ist immer
Eins es sei denn
So Grab
Muss man
Den Github Rev Name
Gräven, was?
Grä, Grä, Grä, Grä
Greppen
Ja
Da steht
Dann sowas drin wie V 003
Oder sowas
Also chat ich glaube
Ich glaube es funktioniert
Ich mein
Mehr als abkacken kann es ja nicht
Oder?
Geht Status
Push
Komm mit
In English sowas
Push
Master
Ok jetzt taggen wir das ganze
Git
Tag
Version 6
Github Push Tag
Github Push Tags
So und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob es funktioniert
Action
Ja das dauert jetzt 2 Minuten
Weil der Cache ist längst expired
Da muss jetzt das ganze Ding neu bauen
Das dauert jetzt kurz
Lass uns nochmal kurz
Überlegen ob die Logik die ich hier gebaut habe
Irgendwie Sinn ergibt
Release 1
So er greppt nach dem
Nach der Technummer in Package Build
Wir sind auch im richtigen Ort da drinnen
Dort wo es Package Build gibt
So
Wenn die Dinge gleich sind
Wenn er die schon findet
Dann Increase da das Release um 1
Ansonsten
Und dann setzt er hier entweder das
Increase der Release ein oder eins
Von hier oben
Und danach Replace da die Package Version
Also ich denke das müsste funktionieren
Mal schauen
Ich bin mal gespannt ob das jetzt klappt
Lulve
Trinken, ihr habt mich wirklich ans Trinken erinnert
Praegge, Chat
Richtig
Praegge mal ne Runde rein
Praegge
Hoffe das es die Versionsnummer
auch nur einmal in der Package Build gibt
Oh ja das ist in der Tat
Eine sehr gute
Frage
Das gibt es nur einmal
und Package Rail gleich
gibt es glücklicherweise auch nur einmal
also alles gut
Ok das sollte funktionieren
Ja nice, nice gepraet Chat
Du du du
Du du du du du du
Du du du du du du du
Ja jetzt mach mal hin ne Mensch
So war das heute auch ohne Scheiß Leute
Ich hab den ganzen Tag auf irgendwelche
Terraform Pipeline Builds
gewartet
Das dauert
ohne Mist
In Google kopaliert das Cluster was zu testen
und abschließend zu gucken ob es geht
Das dauert ungefähr 15-20
Minuten bis der Cluster weg ist
und dann wieder 15-20 Minuten
bis der Cluster da ist. Also ich kann es quasi
so ungefähr 7-8 mal an einem Arbeitstag
testen
und dann ist der Tag vorbei
ok Tom, du kannst schon ausprobieren
das Release müsste da sein
mit einer tollen
super geilen
Changelog Eintrag
hat das jetzt funktioniert?
VmChamp bin
es hat geklappt
neue version da
V006 Package Release 1
genauso wie es sein soll
ok, ich habe es geklappt
ich habe es geklappt
Release 1
genauso wie es sein soll
jetzt müssen wir nur noch warten
bis das User Repo das mitbekommt
bei der gelingen hat schreiben wir ordentliche Release Notes
was haben wir denn jetzt gemacht?
die hatten wir eigentlich die anderen formatiert
also
edit debian12
fixed ubuntu
network
rich
config
fixed watchdog error
error
so, was haben wir sonst noch gemacht?
libwirt
check
add
add startup
aber sonst irgendwas gemacht?
nee, ich glaube das war's
ich glaube das
okay
da ist es leute
neues
our package
eh
achso to exclude
funktioniert
nice
vmchamp
ja ich hab das bild ja das letzte mal noch gefixt
das geht jetzt auch mit dem upgrade immer
okay vmchamp
minus os
debian
oh
achso run
minus minus os
äh winners support
äh winners sollte
in wsl
wenn du libwirt hast und irgendwie libwirt
connected hast dass das was macht
also in wsl gehts auf jeden fall schon
äh in winners selber nicht
aber ich mein gibt es libwirt für winners
wer verwendet libwirt unter winners niemand
oder
oder meinst du winners in a vm
winners in a vm ist
tatsächlich relativ einfach
des problemes dass es halt keine fertigen
cloud images für winners gibt
seit wann orange maus seit heute
guck
.files
wo bloß
comments
seit heute
bibata modern ember
orange maus tiger
den sieht man wenigstens schön
ja
da hatten wir mal
alma linux 9 warum
da braucht man aber glaube ich ein bisschen mehr
memory dass das funktioniert
und ich glaube auch ein bisschen mehr
disk
ja geht nice
der download alter
was sind das für plastic server
schluss mal an
geht ja überhaupt nicht vorwärts
haben wir
inzwischen nf support
nö
weder config
noch nf support
ist das
meinst du wirklich dass das sinnvoll ist
ich mein
os hinten dran schreiben
mit autocomplete ich weiß
ob das ein
riesen zeitersparnis ist
aber mach einen
issue feature request auf
sag config file
und oder nf support
ne mach ruhig
mach hier mach nen issue
dann machen wir das in allen nächsten streams
wir müssen auch die sache
vom serious max einbauen dass man
die ssh keys auswählen kann
ne dass er selbst nen ssh key erzeugt
hat jemand schon
in krafana ein home assistant
ja hab ich mit dem iframe
und die checksum
mit der iframe card
das geht
aber es ist nicht schön
ich würde dir eher empfehlen machen fullscreen
machen tab
auf deinem dashboard dafür
und mach dann
fullscreen das dashboard
ansonsten ist es ein bisschen eklig
und du musst
das krafana dashboard auf
diesen embedded
auf diesen embedded modus schalten
dass es gescheit funktioniert
du kannst nicht einfach
das dashboard verlinken
du musst es als embedded dashboard verlinken
das gibt es irgendwo in krafana gibt es so einen link
also so einen button
kann man drauf drücken
und sagt dann irgendwie
generate code oder so
und da kannst du dann das dashboard raus kopieren
also jetzt einmal
redhead
das ist ein redhead nachbau das ist quasi das
was früher cento s war
aber cento s wurde ja eingestellt
es bootet halt ein bisschen
lahmarschiger als das andere
cento s gibt es ja nicht mehr
äh ja
wie wärs mit ensemble
ensemble
das ist eigentlich die
einzige sinnvolle antwort im jahr 2023
für so klassische
server
vms und systeme
die halt nicht öfters weggeschmissen werden
und neu aufgebaut werden sondern lange zeit am stück
vorhanden sind ensemble
das ist das einzige
bei ensemble läuft doch dann einfach das update
ach ne ne du willst
ja wie jetzt
ne du kannst bei ensemble zugucken was er macht
also du kannst
den ausgabe
anzeigen lassen wo er grad ist und was er
an welchem server bei welchem step er gerade ist
oder was willst du denn wissen
willst du wissen welche pakete
er alle geupgraded hat bei diesem upgrade
oder was willst du machen
ach vorher
also du willst quasi ein ne ja gut dass du kannst dir das kannst du dir auch das kannst du dir auch in
einem n simple playbook zusammenbauen du könntest dir also die einfachste variante die mir jetzt
einfallen wird ist du startest in ein playbook entweder mit options oder du hast ein eigenes
playbook dafür was dir quasi anzeigt was er updaten würde auf allen kisten und dann hast du
einen zweiten step wo du es dann applies oder ein zweites playbook wo du es applies das geht
bestimmt noch cooler das müssen die n simple die n simple experten hier wieder wissen unsere
alma vm funktioniert ich bin mir nicht sicher ob n simple interaktive rückfragen kann kann
n simple interaktive rückfragen
anscheinend ja moment aber das macht da nicht pause das ist für die variablen dann irgendwie
also ich habe keine ahnung ob n simple zwischendrin stoppen kann und ich fragt möchten sie das tun
da bin ich das weiß ich nicht das habe ich noch nicht gemacht
es gibt bestimmt irgendwelche sachen also mich würde schwer wundern wenn das mit
ansible nicht gescheit funktioniert
ansible kann pausieren auf input warten ja dann ist ja easy dann machs mit ansible
also es muss mit ansible gehen ansible ist eigentlich das beste tool für solche sachen
ich kann aber nicht alle ansible sachen aus dem kopf ich bin nicht der ultra krasse ansible checker
kann den kram lesen ich kann das updaten ich kann das anpassen aber jetzt alle sachen im
detail weiß ich nicht ok tomba die hat alles funktioniert jetzt da würde ich sagen war
doch erfolgreicher fixing stream denkst du es lohnt sich ansible auf jeden fall lohnt sich
das ansible ist das einzig sinnvolle tool zur aktuellen zeit in dieser produktkategorie
bei dir geht es nicht wieso was geht bei dir nicht ist das must have also wenn du auch nur
entfernt was mit dealungsservern zu tun hast ja
Bhag favorit
seles Красner
Satana
Bist du unter Ubuntu?
Hast du ETC QEMU?
Vielleicht ist ja bei dir schon was. Hast du da vorher schon mal rumgebastelt oder so?
Dann müssen wir das das nächste Mal nochmal nachstellen.
Hast du eine virtuelle Bridge schon? Hast du etcqemo?
Und hast du etcqemo-bridge.conf? Und was steht da drinne?
Guck mal ob es bei dir etcqemo-bridge.conf gibt.
Arch install first time ist gerade richtig pains jam ja verständlich.
Aber wenn du es mit dem arch installer machst ist es eigentlich gar kein ding.
Die installation ist dann halt durch aber es hat noch nix eingerichtet.
Also ich mach
Elper C Amort u plus s Reicht es nicht?
Ach ne Moment, du meinst doch was anderes. Ja Phipps guck mal ob da ein ATC hatte ich nicht.
Ja aber mit der neuen Version macht er das. Also wenn du die neue Version hast und er
dich fragt ob er ne Bridge anlegen soll und du sagst yes, dann leg da mal zumindest ATC QEMU an.
Ich mein das muss jetzt funktionieren. Guck mal, ich kann das jetzt nochmal löschen.
Ich bin blöd Leute, wir haben keinen Snapshot gemacht. Warum haben wir denn keinen Snapshot
gemacht? Das ist ja doof. Ich hätte gesagt ich installiere es jetzt einfach nochmal neu und dann
gucken wir ob es geht. Wir haben ja noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit. Schadet ja nichts. Du hattest
die Standard Bridge aktiv, die LibVirt beim installieren mitbringt. Moment, LibVirt bringt
beim installieren eine Standard Bridge mit. Ich dachte die ist standardmäßig nicht dabei.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich dann ein Bug. Das wusste ich gar nicht. Dann, okay ich installiere
mal, ich installiere mal schnell nochmal ein Ubuntu. Das dauert ja 5 Minuten, oder? Das
ist per Default da, aber aus. Okay, das kann natürlich sein, dass das ein Problem ist.
Ich installiere das gerade mal neu. Das probieren wir mal aus. Und dann muss ich,
erinnere mich mal dran, dass ich einen Snapshot, einen Snapshot mache.
Dass ich einen Snapshot mache, dass ich das nicht immer wieder neu installieren muss.
Das mit Perch alleine reicht nicht.
Da ist er wieder. Ich dachte eigentlich, ich habe den Mist ausgeschaltet.
Ich meine, es geht ja zackig. Komm mal, ich finde es gut,
dass der VMA Tools dabei hat. Habe ich den Installer kaputt gemacht?
Ich bin gespannt, ob das geht. Aber gut, wenn er standardmäßig einen Bridge mitbringt,
dann könnte durchaus sein, dass das nicht funktioniert. Doch, das sollte auch funktionieren.
Wenn man im Installer beim manuellen Partition im ZFL als Route ausfällt,
crash der Installer. Du meinst dem neuen, oder? Du meinst jetzt Ubuntu 23.04.
Ja, Multipass ist halt Ubuntu-only und ich fand's auch eklig zu installieren.
Ach geht das über Snap? Ich hab's mal selbst kompiliert unter Arch, das hat irgendwie ein
Viertelstunde gedauert. Weil ich da keine Nested-Virtualisierung aktiviert hab.
Was ich vielleicht mal machen sollte. Wie sind denn die Settings für Nested-Virtualisierung?
Die muss ich mir mal kurz angucken hier. Manu, manuell install, Linux 2020, ja ist egal. Finish.
Okay, wie sind die Settings für Nested? Und wo stellt man das überhaupt? Ein Nested in
Nested Virtualisierung. Hat jemand einen Plan? Wird Manager Nested? Okay, how to enable Nested
Virtualisation? Yes, okay, denn der FM-Champ ist fast gefixt, ja. Enabling Nested Activate,
ah, Moment, das ist eine Kernel-Geschichte, oder wie? Oh, das ist ja eklig. Obei, nee,
Moment, ich hab's, ich... Show Virtual Hardware, CPU, click CPU, there are two options, host,
pass to... Was? Moment, ist Nested Virtualisierung jetzt da schon aktiviert, oder was? Bin ich
einfach nur zu PP-Gar gewesen und hab' das zu sehen? Moment, ergeblich ist Nested Virtualisierung
schon jetzt an oder muss ich das muss ich das so check if nested virtualisation is enabled
yes
ja ich will aber sehen ob es aktuell enabled ist
das ist was muss ich dann machen mod mod mod info kvm kvm intel
und da jetzt irgendwie krept minus i nestet fast so richtig macht okay keine ahnung
wir probieren das jetzt einfach mal hier aus ok heißt das nestet virtualisierung geht jetzt
standardmäßig schon oder dann machen wir mal oder das wird was null wir machen wirklich mal
virtu vm in vm dass das das wird jetzt high IQ shit ram aber da war mal ein bisschen memory
geben wir dem ding mal 2g memory und ein bisschen ein bisschen mehr disk so vor allem
exzellent high IQ chat
hallo ich hab doch disconnected so snapshot
aber wir testen es jetzt erstmal hier drinnen in der vm
vm in der vm
so sudo-e install virtmanager update ok ist gut
bin ich ja mal gespannt ob nested virtualisierung tut
so jetzt downloaden wir den aktuellen
aktuellen vm champ für das das das jetzt ok wir machen jetzt nested
nested virtualisierung ich meine das ist eine vm darin läuft eine vm und darin
lasse ich jetzt wieder eine vm laufen
allerdings wir führen ja nur sehr leichtgewichtige linux sachen und und
bisschen cli zeug aus das kann mein rechner schon ab
meine es ist jetzt nicht als wäre der irgendwie besonders besonders schlecht
wird seppchen ja schon
so wie rebooten mal
weil ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob das mit den kernel updates so funktioniert hat
das ist ein tool wo du kommando zeilen bei kommando zeile schnell vms erstellen
kannst wenn du keine grafische oberfläche brauchst
das war irgendwie kaputt unter ubuntu und das haben wir heute gefixt wobei es unter
manchen bedingungen so wie ich das gerade vernommen habe immer noch kaputt ist
plus x vm jam ok ist standardmäßig ein interface da nein ist es nicht
run yes
o matte
ok nested virtualisierung ist nicht an
obwohl er sagt das nested virtualisierung alles how to enable nested virtualisation
ist in use ja ach weiß dass es in use ist
ja moment stopp stopp gibt es nicht
user in richtiger gruppe brauche man glaube ich gar nicht
wenn er hier sagt kvm not supported ne ne ne ne das ist auf jeden fall ok wir müssen
noch mal kurz löschen wir müssen wahrscheinlich sagen lip wird stopp dass es geht system ctl stopp
lip wird und jetzt unload vom kernel modul und jetzt nestet gleich eins laden und jetzt
lip wird wieder starten und jetzt
jetzt sollte es ja eigentlich wieder funktionieren
jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir explizit nested virtualisierung eingeschaltet
würde ich eigentlich erwarten dass ich den vm champ runterladen kann und dass
auch nested nested virtualisiert
so install update
boi das flutscht überlegt euch mal für das dass es jetzt schon eine vm in der vm ist also da kann
man sich echt nicht beschweren so ein großer unterschied zu native ist das nicht
bisschen langsamer ok aber ist jetzt es ist nicht irgendwie dass unbenutzbar langsam wäre also wer
schon mal versucht hat in raspberry pie also eine armenkiste über koemo zu emulieren der weiß was
langsam bedeutet das ist richtig richtig langsam ein emulierter raspberry pie oder
raspberry emulierte armenkiste na max du hast es auch schon gemacht das ist abartig
nee dein pie 2 ist garantiert nicht langsamer glaubt mir das ist richtig langsam emulierter
raspberry emulierter raspberry pie ok pause chat mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert
geht nicht ok nestet nestet virtualisation mag er nicht das ist ja doof
ja ja genau noch mal nestet in ja ja nestet ach nee da muss es nicht angeschaltet sein
da will ich ja in nichts noch mal nestet ich mein ich kann das ich kann das machen nee nee
das wir können hier machen modpro-r kvm intel und jetzt nests aber das ist egal das das bringt
nix okay das funktioniert nicht nestet nestet virtualisierung okay das aber doof dass es nicht
geht muss ich mal schlau machen wie das kann man garantiert aktivieren 100 pro weiß ich weiß bloß
nicht wie aber das das geht garantiert kann ich wetten hallo meint hatte das nicht vorher
noch verämer tools wo sind die jetzt hin und das hier für kacke schon wieder ah mann
vorhin hatten haben die doch noch verämer tools gehabt gibt's nicht mehr outdated
overrated gebetet ja das soll man update machen wir laden schon mal den von github runter
und dann schauen wir mal ob es unter unter ubuntu jetzt funktioniert
o snap wenn ich das schon sehe ich verstehe bis heute nicht warum ubuntu beziehungsweise
canonical so auf diese snap geschichte abfährt ich meine es muss ja irgendwie müssen damit
irgendwelche wirtschaftlichen interessen verfolgen aber ich verstehe es halt irgendwie nicht weil
man weder feiern die leute snap noch haben sie irgendwie ich verstehe es nicht keine ahnung
in ihrem plan warum hier verämmer
warum die feier tool sind nicht mal funktionieren ging doch vorhin noch
ab install open vm tools das muss man auch vorher auch nicht installieren
muss wenn das vorher noch mal installieren das war doch vorher drauf
downloads sudo update jetzt hatten wir sudo ab install virt manager
oh nee wie war das jetzt noch mal unter Ubuntu mittlere maustaste
überall andere shortcuts
ah das ist schon ein bisschen schneller nicht nestet virtualisiert
ok
chmods v6 vmchem vmchem run
ok da ist standardmäßig ein interface am start das macht höchstwahrscheinlich problems
das ist ja eine richtig hängengebliebene config mann die haben ein standard interface
dabei als bridge was aber so vorkonfiguriert ist dass es kaputt ist das ist ja mal richtig
dämlich alda jubantu baut für den engelmist lepwirt not running hat natürlich runn lepwirt
ja das heißt man müsste jetzt quasi einmal okay ich weiß aber wie ich fixe das ist tatsächlich
relativ easy wieso ist der default kaputt weil es keine etc qemo bridgeconf gibt wo das erlaubt
wird das default network so und jetzt jetzt funktioniert es ok das heißt der einfachste
fix dafür ist tatsächlich also mein das hier das hier macht er ja
dann verstehe ich nicht leute ja die brauchst du dann verstehe ich nicht warum das es müsste
doch eigentlich funktionieren ich meine hier lege ich die vielleicht muss man das
netzwerk noch mal starten und stoppen oder sowas das verstehe ich nicht das snapshot
gut dass ich es geschnappschottet habe
ah mist ok ich muss doch mal snapshotten gleich ist grad ziemlich an unusable so skip no
next next dann terminal sudo install open vm tools desktop
dass die pc speaker an haben schon grausam sudo update
da machen wir gleich noch ein screenshot äh kein screenshot snapshot
magst du das dringend erinnern? ja danke habe ich gerade
das sind sounds vom terminal ja das ist aber normalerweise der pc speaker weil wenn du das
pc speaker modul unloadest dann macht er auch keine sounds mehr
ganz einfach
wie kommt man überhaupt auf die idee dass es eine gute eine gute idee ist so was überhaupt
standardmäßig einzuschalten ich meine niemand braucht das doch das fackt doch alle nur ab
so jetzt noch mal snapshot
einfach verändern wenn ausmuten das geht auch ganz aber auch pc speaker anlauten
im moment ja doch jetzt mal snapshot bevor wir wird installieren wer weiß ob wir das nicht noch
ein paar mal probieren wollen so und jetzt ist die frage an welcher warum ist warum ist
so bunthuse da wieder so so extra wurschtig zudo ab install wird manager ops vertippt
warum ist ubuntu da schon wieder so komisch dass das nicht funktioniert
so also sprich nach dem installieren haben wir ein default network interface was kaputt ist
aber es ist da so wir gehen erstmal downloads
so und jetzt mag er nicht weil das interface da ist
ja ok ich weiß woran es liegt ich weiß woran es liegt das problem ist
das oh das ist ja richtig dumm da fällt mir jetzt auf die schnelle keine lösung ein das
problem ist wenn es die fault interface da ist da geht er es gar nicht in das if rein das heißt
ich müsste vor dem if gucken ob das da ist und dann schon mal anlegen dass die fault funktioniert
ne das die fault funktioniert nicht dass das die fault ist kaputt dass die fault ist kaputt weil
es keine etc qemo bridge gibt was funktioniert ist eine vm mit user mode networking anlegen
das ist dann aber kein bridge network was die bridge benutzt ja ja also du kannst vms erstellen
die können ins netzwerk aber nicht quasi als bridge über über diese angelegte bridge das
nicht das ist das ist das ist ziemlicher ziemlicher müll wie das so punto macht muss ich mal sagen
andere distribution machen das wohl nicht
okay das ist anscheinend wirklich so gedacht
ne ne mit eigener bridge das funktioniert nicht da habe ich auch schon dran gedacht
ich weiß nicht mehr genau das funktioniert nicht das funktioniert einmal glaube ich wegen
berechtigung nicht richtig
ich weiß es nicht das es es es funktioniert nicht also es ist oder es ist zumindest keine gute idee
ich kann ihr nicht mehr sagen warum da habe ich mir auch schon Gedanken gemacht einfach eine
eigene achja ich weiß warum du kannst zwar eine eigene bridge anlegen aber die ist in
der standard QEMO config nicht erlaubt es ist nur wir wirbr 0 erlaubt in der QEMO conf ich meine
man könnte natürlich die QEMO conf editieren und dort die eigene bridge reinschreiben
es würde auch funktionieren vielleicht ist es tatsächlich gar keine so schlechte ide
bevor man jetzt ewig mit ubuntu rum kämpft beziehungsweise allgemein also ich müsste
das hier quasi ich müsste das quasi davor machen oder oder oder if default bridge
gleich gleich null oder pile pile not exists das müsste eigentlich doch auch gehen oder etc qemu
bridge konf
das ist glaube ich auch
das das müsste es glaube ich fixen ich glaube das müsste es fixen ja das mal ausprobieren
ok geht nicht judo minus ab install open ssh server er neu kompilieren ich weiß es ja noch
gar nicht ich kriege es doch hier so gar nicht drauf doch ach fange ich auch schon mit ip
konfig an mensch lull if konfig wir haben 30 wieder nicht ipa if konfig beste ok es ist
tmctl start ok so jetzt sollten wir da drauf kommen
cd repo vm champ ja macht nix
moment passt doch eigentlich das einzige was ich noch machen muss ist
nee eigentlich gut so
den kram muss ich noch löschen testen.sh
build 0.6
alter wo ist es denn jetzt
build.sh da das da will ich da machen
ja da denke ich immer nicht dran max ich weiß dass es das gibt
aber ich denke da nicht dran
so kopieren wir das mal rüber
und gucken ob es dann
ach so ja sei mal nicht so pingelig
ich meine ich kann das löschen aber warum war was hat er jetzt für schmerzen
ach so moment es liegt gar nicht am key das liegt überhaupt nicht am key
das ist der falsche user oder wie heißt denn jetzt der user
post verification ja ok ist gut wie war das offiziell ssh key keygen minus r
glaube ich aber warum hat es jetzt mit striktors keycheck nicht funktioniert
gut wie dem auch sei jetzt schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert was wir gebaut haben
😍
👤
ahh Moment
editor
du sing sie
light
was was was ist hier
ah ich nur oh nee
ich habe da oben den if dass es dann ran vorbei geht
ja ok ja das muss ich mir morgen überlegen
das muss ich mir morgen überlegen da fällt mir jetzt gar nichts zu ein
ok alles klar chat wir sehen uns morgen macht's gut bis denn zu